Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
A couple episodes ago, we finally set sail
in the wonderful world of hair simulations.
And today we shall continue our journey in
this domain.
But this time, we are going to talk about
hair modeling.
So first, what is the difference between hair
simulation and modeling?
Well, simulation is about trying to compute
the physical forces that act on hair strands,
thereby showing to the user, how they would
move about in reality.
Modeling, however, is about obtaining geometry
information from a photograph.
This geometry information we can use in our
movies and computer games.
We can also run simulations on them and see
how they look on a digital character.
Just think about it, the input is one photograph
and the output is a digital 3D model.
This sounds like a remarkably difficult problem.
Typically something that a human would do
quite well at, but it would be too labor-intensive
to do so for a large number of hairstyles.
Therefore, as usual, neural networks enter
the fray by looking at the photograph, and
trying to estimate the densities and distributions
of the hair strands.
The predicted results are then matched with
the hairstyles found in public data repositories,
and the closest match is presented to the
user.
You can see some possible distribution classes
here.
Not only that, but the method is fully automatic,
which means that unlike most previous works,
it doesn't need any guidance from the user
to accomplish this task.
As a result, the authors created an enormous
dataset with 50 thousand photographs and their
reconstructions that they made freely available
for everyone to use.
The output results are so spectacular, it's
almost as if we were seeing magic unfold before
our eyes.
The fact that we have so many hairstyles in
this dataset also opens up the possibility
of editing, which is always quite a treat
for artists working in the industry.
The main limitation is a poorer reconstruction
of regions that are not visible in the input
photograph, but I think that goes without
saying.
It is slightly ameliorated by the fact that
the public repositories contain hairstyles
that make sense, so we can expect results
of reasonable quality even for the regions
we haven't seen in the input photograph.
As always, please let me know below in the
comments section whether you have found everything
understandable in this episode.
Was it easy to digest?
Was there something that was not easy to follow?
Your feedback, as always, is greatly appreciated.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!